okay let's start with one year for and
I'm playing Michael yeah nice telling me
1988 world under-18 champion 1993
British champion haven't had a good
results and smooth for 20 years that fat
and he doesn't have a name in them maybe
Michael Hennigan I think there's an
international master Hannegan but i'm
not sure if it's this person okay we got
them a night off and I usually play this
Bishop e2 line because the other ones
don't even know no less yeah I always
feel I should I should move the King to
make sure that nothing bad happens on
now on this diagonal a 71 okay my ideas
to threaten a 50 I just drops back hello
hey Chester goes to the side interesting
yeah if i take i probably probably have
nothing
I'm at 92 also looks quite stupid so
let's let's just take it Bishop d3 up
shop f3 whoo yeah d three RF three
probably here
yeah this is mostly because maybe i need
even a queen d3r something up that at
some point to cover the football like I
certainly all right um maybe this one to
threaten 95 maybe this irritates in a
bit and he cannot go d5 I just take it
Oh still 95 maybe
95 night XD 565 may be on or am i
playing playing this tool to quickly
down I have something something much
better what about d far above re5 and
then 95 at the end so maybe an idea now
don't think so let's go for this 95 I
take on d5 Queenie one rookie one he
will have a really bad structure that
should be worth enough that i am that i
get the pawn back conveniently like
Queen one rookie one yeah and I have
Bishop to Bishop b6 yeah oh this is a
good enough nice coincidence that i have
the special be six month this might be a
useful resource I literally just thought
okay takes on d5 and I'll play that work
T 1 and get the porn back but maybe I
have Bishop e6 taking the rope and
attacking him if he had taken he can
play rook e8 so it's strongly not that
dangerous even but it's a possibility
yeah okay I need to take and now be
should be six is just them very very
little just rupee aid the question is
how do i get the porn bag maybe I need
to play this anyway yes after if he goes
there i mean i need to do the center way
or came let some activate hi Scott Roxy
form it's also also move but i still get
back at d5
yeah just ripped if I may so it should
be okay what's a slightly worried no not
I getting this back on a good day of
what even hasn't known something okay
what you for one rookie forward I can't
drop back it's not not leading too much
maybe look-see for what I have no don't
have be three who the roxy 40 p 3
episode III should still be okay
yeah rookie for look-see for one of
those moves I take f 6m it's of course
it's bad he takes f 1 f 6 hunting I need
to do this but rookie aid of course
group d 3 i'm a bit bit tired while i
was taking his sweet time really repay
form that i come on at it envoys there
and i do that lube takes a for should be
it should be good for me really hits
this ruckus this is an off-site piece
and have them i have bishop deform it's
just one idea but rugby sixes good young
rugby six and just rupee seven yeah this
is simple and good just doing this pawn
rook a to king of three i also have the
better King now
yeah I can just take it Ruby five it's
also a dead end game
yeah how to to play this just let's
first get the King all of any checks on
the second rank and ce4 probably and
then be four yeah be 45 this looks ok ok
c5 is playing shape to deform so let's
say use the King c5 will be five
reliever I can't can I can do that first
yeah yeah yeah I am ok I overlooked that
so that too late
hi morning yeah yeah I know it's a cheap
trick but and what's the time winning
and then in any case probably but I just
invested some time and try to win on the
on position I've g4 have this was a bit
bit annoying it's um it's technically
winning but don't do know I was writing
thanks this is real people are ready
it's very emeriti that there's some
dialogue yeah thanks for watching